on this episode I get pissed off
[Music]
this
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 150 point 5 of the
askgaryvee show and if you feel the
energy off the get it's because I'm
pissed that this is not episode 152
because we did a very special 360 video
episode out there that you're all gonna
freak for because you didn't even watch
this show and then click and see
everything around there's a ton of [ __ ]
going on and Vayner people ask me and
it's incredible it's phenomenal but I
tape the two goddamn days ago I expected
it go up there we had the shoot we used
a vaynermedia
video production team not our squad but
nobody from my squad said that that
wasn't gonna be up that day and then
then I hear at the end of this week or
early next week I'm like what kind of
[ __ ] timing is that that would've
meant that I don't have an episode for
like eight nine days unacceptable I'm
here to tape episodes so III don't
understand I get angry then I then I put
a little pressure all of a sudden yeah
okay we'll have it the other day
yesterday no show I put out an Instagram
picture said you missed the show it's
coming tomorrow I look like a dick face
I don't like looking like a dick face
and then today shortly it's gonna be
done no I have no show and then Steve on
the way back like I don't know I think
you should do something else because I'm
not sure if it's gonna be done at the
end of the day but I'm not either so
we're doing episode one fifty point five
in between 150 which is last show that I
did I don't know seven hundred years ago
and this episode that I taped years ago
that's gonna come out one day episode
151 the only saving grace is it's going
to be so phenomenal and that you're
gonna watch it 19 times gonna try to
find any different things might be your
first 360 video experience in a phone or
on desktop you know have to put on the
oculus or any of that stuff you'll be
able to watch and click it's gonna be
cool but not happy about it just not
happy about it
uh that's it gonna have a good show got
it how to bang this one out because I
think I'm a Jets prediction out all
right idea let's get into the show oh it
was better go
Malik asks how can I become a really
good listener Malik I think good
listening comes from actual intent and
actually wanting to be a good listener
like anything in the world when you want
to beat something be something and beat
I want to beat some things right now if
you want to be something you need to
actually mean it meaning like I decided
I wanted to get in better shape and
health I just went out and did it like
you just like worms are such [ __ ] you
know what's the matter with a lot of
people like a lot of people a lot of
people watching this show a lot of
people in the world a lot of people is
there's only actions you know I always
talk about intent is what matters right
like a DNA I'm public tenant every time
with that I get tons of comments with
like scripture from the Bible I think
I'm apologize I'm not up on that like
but I think I'm a pretty sure where it's
like intent is a good the leading things
like basically it says like intense
great but like you can say you have good
intent but if your actions are you're
doing wrong things like Anna and I get
it like to me like intent is the
starting point so I think it's nice to
start there but I agree I agree words
are the problem Malik you want to be a
good listener be a good listener
like more like like when somebody's
talking listen like when when you listen
when somebody's saying something listen
and try to do that cuz listening is not
just listening listening is listening
and then doing something about it
look there's a comma there's a the
definition of listening is consuming it
and doing something about it
problem is most people are doing things
about it it's a whole lot of talking a
whole lot of talking going on in the
game Jess Jess asks I love you man and
everything you do but I also hate you
because I'm a little jelly of your
success how can I get past that like
jelly like Beyonce jelly like my tone to
a sir I'm jealous I understand
thanks for the reaction you thought I
was
I'm not confused yeah I get it I mean
look I think it's I think being jealous
of my success is good I'm jealous of
other people's success but not really
meaning try to change it from a negative
to a positive I'm inspired by people's
success even though you know being
inspired by somebody and being jealous
of them is literally just an inch off
and they're cousins they're kissing
cousins being inspired by somebody being
jealous of someone is literally a
kissing cousins game and so I'm too
egotistical to say that I'm jealous of
somebody but I'm definitely motivated
and recognized much like the last answer
the results are the results I'm talking
big [ __ ] guys like I don't know if you
understand what I'm doing I'm really
setting myself up for failure I've told
the world that I'm gonna buy the New
York Jets I need to amass ten billion
dollars to buy the New York Jets if I am
asked 1 billion dollars a stunning
percentage of the people watching this
show will define me as not winning
because the narrative has been built
that this is my thing like do you
understand that when Woody Johnson
decides to sell or passes away in the
estate's up for sale in 20 30 years got
Willy woody 50 years for you god bless
whatever but whenever that happens if
I'm not the person at that point with
the narrative I'm gonna paint all these
years that buys it people will be like
oh sorry Gary or in whatever to the
Twitter or the Facebook of the world
then is which is even worse because
probably give me like Holograms and
people to just pop up me like sorry I
literally have like Princess Leia 58
million Princess Leia is being like
sorry dude really what she got it I just
gonna be loser City USA I'm setting
myself up because was the question
jealous because you know you know
because I haven't I put myself in such a
weird position of insane success to
justify success in the narrative that
I'm painting so I'm inspired and I'm
challenged by the people my friend
Travis can buy the Jets I mean he did it
like this is it my homie that I hung out
with five minutes ago they're like I
introduced that Tahoe TechTalk 2009 is
this is the guy that none of you know on
this panel but you're all gonna know
which I'm trying to figure out if I film
of but like like you know like like it's
amazing it's amazing so anyway those
kind of people I'm not I'm not jealous
of Travis I'm inspired
that he executed at that level so I
would say that man just likes make a
little switch in your DNA and understand
being jealous of me or anybody else me
being jealous you guys anybody be
jealous is a really backwards defensive
trait it's gonna do you absolutely no
good
switching it slightly until I'm inspired
by that and I want to climb higher than
that is a really good place to go so you
need still a little more goodness and
get a little of the badness out of there
I think the way to get badness out is to
talk it out you know this is why I think
everybody should see a therapist or or
have some outlet you know to get bad you
need to out you need to talk out bad bad
staying in your heart and soul will
corrode you and it's a cancer spit out
your bad too many people use their loved
ones or the closest person as the person
they spit to and then that person has a
weird relationship with them find your
outlet you know my mom and I use each
other because we're able we got lucky we
can handle it but you know if you don't
have that lucky relationship you need to
find a different outlet thank you I'm
done yeah each were you asks what
lessons if any did you find for Mad Men
how was vaynermedia differently run than
Sterling Cooper yeah I don't know who
Sterling Cooper is I've not watched one
minute of Mad Men I want to I think it's
kind of cool but I've never watched Mad
Men which is interesting because I'm
building like I have you guys watching
or an episode do you okay do you great
so as Mad Men is that agency the one
that became the best agent like is the
narrative play on those eight years that
they became the big dogs always we're
good great so I I really want to watch
it you know what's really cool is I'm
glad I didn't watch it because I know so
much more about the ad world now that
when and if I ever watch it on a
vacation on a binge maybe me and Lizzie
just want to check out and like laying
up in a cabin and Utah for four days and
watch TV shows straight through which
sounds really exciting
cuz I wanted I love checking out on my
vacations I'm always I always laugh
people don't think I mean I checked out
on vacations I don't give a crap SAS
yeah you're like that one
so so I would watch the show I don't
know what they're doing I don't care
what anybody's doing I'm doing my thing
mine my way always from the gut I don't
care what anybody else does or how they
do it my way is always better cuz it's
for me and I know myself and I know how
I'm gonna win and so I don't watch other
things I don't look at other people
I don't need Norton any Northstars I do
me the whole way always all the way
through is he gonna be here wasn't gonna
be here
go ahead hey Gary its Mark Cuban I'd
like to know what your go-to interview
questions are questions you have to ask
every candidate that you interview every
time requiring - she was with a nice hat
I like that mark who's accomplished the
in his life the goal I have which is to
own a professional sports team so I like
that I know a lot of you are fans of
Mark and he's a really smart dude knows
his stuff with the interviews I really
try to reverse-engineer what the person
wants I try to break down a person in
her interview within the first few
minutes of meeting them to fully trust
and believe in me which is something I
try to do with all these guys on a daily
basis that's a never-ending battle from
the day I try to interview - four years
into our relationship how can I
disproportionally get their trust
because I know my intent and my actions
map to doing good things 96% of the time
and and I'd like to think a hundred but
sometimes there's a miscommunication and
if it is the right thing and so I try to
get them to tell me the truth
are you things like I want to come to
vaynermedia to steal all your ideas and
see how you do it so I can start my own
agency and steal some of the people here
to start it I'm not bothered by that I'm
like cool great Stefan if that's your
plan I'll help you I'll speed that up
but I expect you to work your [ __ ]
face/off 19 hours a day for next three
years for me to then help you start your
own thing I don't care what you want I
don't care I want to know what it is so
I try to get to that place very quickly
I think the other thing that I'm always
doing as well is at the same token as
I'm hearing those answers I'm trying to
feel out the person I'm complete when I
interview there's times where I'm in
complete Charlie Brown mode I might not
even hear a word you're saying it is wah
wah wah wah wah I'm just going by the
feel the feel is what has guided me the
whole time
not necessarily the words there's no
black and white answer I also find it
intriguing that I ask almost everybody
about siblings it's maybe because I love
my brother and sister so much and I
don't judge it like your own only child
I don't say oh well you don't work well
with others all that dumb cliché [ __ ] I
know plenty of only children the most
charismatic of all time and can you work
with everybody I know only children that
cliche don't play well with the others I
know plenty of jerk-offs in this office
that have 17 brothers and sisters and
don't know how to play and so that's not
what I'm looking for I don't know even
know why I asked that question mark
about the siblings but it makes I'd like
to think in a nice way it's because of
my relationship with mine and how I like
it
and so it's really the feeling and
trying to reverse-engineer the person
that's what I'm looking for mark those
are the insights my man
Shannon asks how do you feel about
mediums Lou logo I love their simplicity
and this new logos ruined that for me
Shannon this is an interesting question
I'm an investor in medium it was the
first investment we made in vain or RC
when I transitioned to that world I'm a
humongous fan I am on the record
thinking that EV Williams is one of the
less than a handful executives in the
world that most understands consumer
behavior of the modern internet world
he's proving it blogger Twitter medium
he's a beast talk about somebody that is
inspirational to me and I'm competitive
with because street shops coming out of
angle that being said this is one of the
single worst logo shifts I've ever seen
I was devastated the other day I didn't
read about it and hear about it got on a
plane like my app updated and I'm like
where's my black what is this piece of
crap holy crap I hate it I'm scared that
this is gonna be passed on to medium
employees and the designer that made it
sees this I here's the good news it
doesn't matter what I think this is one
man's point of view
there's plenty people that may like it
people I don't I don't know just the
answer to the question straight I really
don't like it I feel like it blends in
with all the other stuff where's the
other one now I could be old man McGee
and I just got used to the other one I
don't know but they answer it straight I
don't like it at all
but here's the best part about names and
logos it doesn't matter if they execute
on the product and the service and the
narrative and the user experience and
many other things I truly believe the
easiest thing to get over is the name
and the logo it's the execution it's a
good way to round up this whole thing
right how do you be a good listener you
don't talk about it you do it what do
you think about this logo or name it
doesn't matter because what you execute
is what the end result is that it's just
a very good narrative for this show and
this theme of 150 point 5 X owns which
is it's about what you do keep talking
you know why I talk because I backed
that [ __ ] up and it feels double good
but a lot of you were talking and never
back it up period and you need to start
backing it up as a matter of fact let me
remind you one more time
I didn't talk [ __ ] at all until I was 30
years old and already had the win on the
board to be able to talk about it so for
a lot of the youngsters why don't you go
out and execute it and then talk [ __ ]
all of you social media or life coach
experts at 23 [ __ ] out of here with that
and number two all your 40 year olds
complaining about this than the other
thing go do something about it you're a
grown-ass man you're a grown-ass woman
stop talking about not being able to do
it or it's so hard or I don't get it or
it's different or these 20 year olds are
lazy stop complaining go do go do doing
doing execution is the only narrative
what you leave on the table as your body
of work is the game right and that's
that simple as that
period good you keep asking questions ah
keep answering them oh I forgot my Jets
prediction my New York Jets prediction I
think the Jets roll in Sheldon
Richardson's back number 91 I'm super
pumped to see him back on the field I
think it matters I think it slows down
the Redskins run I do think the Redskins
are better than most people think
I scouted them a little bit last week
against the Falcons they impressed me
tremendously I do think that they played
really well I'm a little bit scared
about their defense
I think our offense is slightly
overrated in certain pockets it's gonna
be an intriguing matchup but I think
there's a chance that the defense just
completely shuts down the Redskins I
think Cousins throws a lot of
questionable passes and so I think the
Jets prevail at a home 22:10 Jets over
the Redskins see ya how much does Rick
the 23 year old get and getting the
truth because the number isn't high
explained let's go further I want to
know how a 23 year old so let me ask you
a question yeah don't you just do for
yourself yeah that's the real question
right like cool if you know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about do it for
yourself
I do I work harder and I'm smarter than
all my 22 year olds I'm better at social
media than everybody at vaynermedia I'm
looking at them right now just to remind
that like so so so honestly I think
you're rolling with like trying to razz
them rad yourself like why are you
trying to funnel through a 23 year old
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]